- [Voiceover] When you have
a multivariable function,
something that takes in
multiple different input values
and let's say it's just
outputting a single number,
a very common thing you wanna do
with an animal like this is Maximize it.
Maximize it, and what this means
is you're looking for the input points,
the values of x and y and
all of its other inputs,
such that the output, f, is as
great as it possibly can be.
Now this actually comes up
all the time in practice
'cause usually when you're dealing
with a multivariable function,
it's not just for fun
and for dealing with abstract symbols,
it's 'cause it actually
represents something,
so maybe it represents
profits of a company,
maybe this is a function
where you're considering
all the choices you can make,
like the wages you give your employees
or the prices of your goods,
or the amount of debt that
you raise for capital,
all sorts of choices that you might make,
and you wanna know what
values should you give
to those choices such
that you maximize profits,
you maximize the thing,
and if you have a function
that models these relationships,
there are techniques, which
I'm about to teach you,
that you can use to maximize this.
Another very common setting,
more and more important these days,
is that of machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
where often what you do
is you assign something
called a cost function to a task,
so maybe you're trying to teach a computer
how to understand audio or
how to read handwritten text.
What you do, is you find a function
that basically tells it how wrong it is
when it makes a guess,
and if you do a good job
designing that function, you
just need to tell the computer
to Minimize, so that's kind
of the flip side, right?
Instead of finding the maximum,
to minimize a certain function,
and if it minimizes this cost function,
that means that it's
doing a really good job
at whatever task you've assigned it,
so a lot of the art and
science of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
comes down to, well,
one finding this cost function
and actually describing difficult tasks
in terms of a function, but
then applying the techniques
that I'm about to teach you
to have the computer minimize that,
and a lot of time and research
has gone into figuring out
ways to basically apply
these techniques, but really
quickly and efficiently.
So, first of all, on a conceptual level,
let's just think about what it means
to be finding the maximum
of a multivariable function.
So I have here the graph
of a two-variable function.
It's something that has
a two-variable input
that we're thinking of as the xy-plane,
and then its output is
the height of this graph,
and if you're looking to maximize it,
basically, what you're
finding is this peak,
kind of the tallest
mountain in the entire area,
and you're looking for the input value,
the point on the xy-plane
directly below that peak,
'cause that tells you
the values of the inputs
that you should put in to
maximize your function,
so how do you go about finding that?
Well, this is perhaps the core observation
in well, calculus, not just
multivariable calculus.
This is similar in the
single variable world,
and there are similarities
in other settings,
but the core observation
is that if you take a
tangent plane at that peak,
so let's just draw in a
it's gonna be completely flat,
but let's say you did this
at a different point, right?
'Cause if you tried to
find the tangent plane,
not at that point, but you
kind of moved it about a bit
to somewhere that's not quite a maximum,
if the tangent plane has
any kind of slope to it,
what that's telling
you is that if you take
very small directions,
kind of in the direction
of that upward slope,
you can increase the
value of your function,
so if there's any slope
to the tangent plane,
you know that you can walk in
some direction to increase it,
but if there's no slope
to it, if it's flat,
then that's a sign that no
matter which direction you walk,
you're not gonna be significantly
increasing the value
of your function.
So what does this mean
in terms of formulas?
Well, if you kind of think back
to how we compute tangent planes
and if you're not very
comfortable with that,
now would be a good time
to take another look
at those videos about tangent planes,
the slope of the plane in each direction,
so this would be the
slope in the x direction,
and then if you look at it
from another perspective,
this would be the slope
in the y direction,
each one of those has
to be zero, and that,
in terms of partial derivatives,
means the partial
derivative of your function,
at whatever point you're
dealing with, right?
So I'll call it x not, y not, as the point
where you're inputting
this, has to be zero,
and then similarly, the partial derivative
with respect to the other
variable, with respect to y,
at that same point, has to be zero,
and both of these have to be true
because let's just take
a look, I don't know,
let's slide it over a little bit here,
this tangent plane, if
you look at the slope,
you imagine walking in the y direction,
you're not increasing your value at all.
The slope in the y direction
would actually be zero,
so that would mean the partial derivative
with respect to y would be
zero, but with respect to x,
when you're moving in
the x direction here,
the slope is clearly negative,
because as you take positive
steps in the x direction,
the height of your tangent
plane is decreasing,
which corresponds to if you
take tiny steps on your graph,
then the height will decrease
in a manner proportional
to the size of those tiny steps.
So what this gives you
here is gonna be a system
of equations where you're
solving for the value of x not
and y not that satisfies
both of these equations,
and in future videos,
I'll go through specific examples of this.
For now, I just wanna give a
good conceptual understanding,
but one very important thing to notice
is that just because this
condition is satisfied,
meaning your tangent plane is flat,
just because that's satisfied,
doesn't necessarily mean
that you've found the maximum.
That's just one requirement
that it has to satisfy,
but for one thing, if you
found the tangent plane
at other little peaks, like
this guy here or this guy here,
or all of the little bumps that go up,
those tangent planes would also be flat,
and those little bumps
actually have a name
because this comes up a lot.
They're called local Minima,
or local Maxima, sorry,
so those guys are called local Maxima.
Maxima is just the plural of Maximum,
and local means that it's
relative to a single point,
so it's basically, if you
walk in any direction,
when you're on that little
peak, you'll go downhill,
so relative to the neighbors
of that little point,
it is a maximum, but relative
to the entire function,
these guys are the shorter
mountains next to Mount Everest,
but there's also another circumstance
where you might find a flat tangent plane,
and that's at the Minima points, right?
If you have the global
Minimum, the absolute smallest,
or also just the local
Minima, these inverted peaks,
you'll also find flat tangent planes.
So what that means, first of all,
is that when you're minimizing a function,
you also have to look
for this requirement,
where all the partial
derivatives are zero,
but it mainly just means
that your job isn't done
once you've done this.
You have to do more tests to check
whether or not what you
found is a local Maximum
or a local Minimum, or a global Maximum,
and these requirements, by the way,
often you'll see them written
in a more succinct form,
where instead of saying
all the partial derivatives
have to be zero, which
is what you need to find,
they'll write it in a different form
where you say that the
gradient of your function, f,
which, of course, is just the vector
that contains all those
partial derivatives.
Its first component is
the partial derivative
with respect to the first variable,
its second component is
the partial derivative
with respect to the second variable,
and if there's more variables,
you would keep going,
you'd say that this whole thing
has to equal the zero vector,
the vector that has nothing
but zeroes as its components,
and it's kind of a
common, abusive notation.
People will just call
that zero vector, zero,
and maybe they'll emphasize
it by making it bold,
because the number zero is not a vector
and often making things bold emphasizes
that you want to be referring to a vector,
but this gives a very succinct way
of describing the requirement.
You're just looking for where
the gradient of your function
is equal to the zero vector, and that way,
you can just write it on
one line, but in practice,
every time that you're expanding that out,
what that means is you find
all of the different partial derivatives,
so this is really just a matter
of notational convenience
and using less space on a blackboard,
but whenever you see this,
that the gradient equals zero,
what you should be thinking of
is the idea that the tangent plane,
the tangent plane is completely flat,
and as I just said, that's not enough
because you might also
be finding local Maxima
or Minima points, but in
multivariable calculus,
there's also another possibility,
a place where the tangent plane is flat,
but what you're looking at
is neither a local Maximum
nor a local Minimum, and this is the idea
of a saddle point, which is
new to multivariable calculus,
and that's what I'll be talking
about in the next video,
so I will see you then.